un français consomme
mais 90 kg de vie
ces deux fois
son grand-père et 3
ce que son art
pères à l'échelle mondiale ces 74
milliards d'animaux terrestres qui sont
abattus chaque année pour notre
consommation de viande
j'ai bien dit milliards ça représente
8,5 millions d'animaux toutes les heures
qui sont abattues dans les abattoirs
pour notre consommation
il ya deux ans j'ai fait le choix de ne
plus participer à ce système est de
devenir végétarien mais en même temps
que j'ai arrêté de manger de la viande
et du poisson
j'ai voulu aller plus loin et découvrir
ce qu'il y avait derrière chaque morceau
de viande
comment les animaux étaient abattus
comment il était élevé et également
qu'est ce qui se cache derrière
l'industrie de la viande quelles sont
leurs pratiques et leurs méthodes
c'est la condition animale qui m'a
poussé à faire ce choix mais vous allez
voir que derrière la condition animale
la consommation de viande a des impacts
beaucoup plus large sur l'environnement
sur la faim dans le monde et encore sur
la santé des consommateurs aujourd'hui
j'ai rien à vous vendre
j'ai pas de livre à vous dédicacez ou de
dvd à vous vendre
j'ai juste besoin de votre empathie et
de votre ouverture d'esprit mon histoire
commence lorsque j'étais petit et je me
souviens avoir demandé à mes parents
est-ce que la côtelette d'agneau que je
mange ici ça appartient aux bébés du
mouton le même agneaux que j'ai en
peluche à côté alors quand on pose ce
genre de questions à ses parents peut
imaginer qu'ils sont un peu gênés
et voilà vous donne une réponse un petit
peu approximative pour son mauvais jeu
de mots noyer le poisson
mais j'avais eu la réponse à mes
questions et ma conscience et est du
coup rassuré et j'allais continuer à
manger de la viande jusqu'à mes 30 ans
jusqu'au jour où mon imaginaire s'est
écroulé c'était un soir je regardais la
télé et je suis tombé sur sur une
émission qui traitait du de l'abattage
des animaux est juste tombé sur ces
vidéos alors là c'est la cifit ici dès
la 6e' des porcs dans les abattoirs et
[Musique]
est du coup c'est à partir de ce moment
là voilà où je me suis dit je vais
regarder quand même ce cette vidéo
jusqu'à présent moi qui suis un amoureux
des animaux j'avais du mal à regarder ce
genre de vidéos et là je ne sais pas
pourquoi je me suis dit je vais regarder
ses vidéos je vais me forcer
c'est à partir de ce moment là où j'ai
remis en question mes habitudes
alimentaires et je me suis posé la
question est ce que mon plaisir
personnel moi j'adore le j'adorais le
goût de la viande est ce que mon plaisir
personnel nécessite de faire souffrir
les animaux de cette manière
en fait vous allez voir que tout le
monde y perd à commencer par les animaux
bien sûr forcément que lorsque je
tombais sur ce genre de vidéos je me
disais les personnes qui travaillent
dans ces abattoirs c'est forcément des
sadiques
c'est des nazis cd et cd acte isolé
voilà le trouver toutes les excuses mais
en fait en y réfléchissant qu'est ce
qu'on demande à ces personnes
on leur demande déjà d'effectuer une
tâche qu'aucun d'entre nous ici présents
ne pourrait faire c'est à dire tu as un
animal ensuite on leur demande de tuer
ces animaux avec empathie en respectant
le bien-être animal sans que l'animal
souffre et à des cadences infernales
lors de mes recherches j'ai découvert
par exemple qu'un ouvrier d'un abattoir
pour ça saignait 900 animaux à l'heure
ça représente
15 seigner à la minute on peut imaginer
avec cette cadence que les erreurs sont
inévitables
alors pour répondre à la question que je
me posais lorsque j'étais petit un
agneau c'est bien le bébé de du mouton
et il a envoyé à l'abattoir entre
lorsqu'il a entre 40 et 60 jours c'est à
dire lorsqu il pèse environ 10 kg et moi
ma fille elle a 18 mois elle pèse
environ 12 kilos et je me dis que dans
la tête d'un agneau qui a 40 et 60 jours
qu'est ce qui doit se passer lorsqu'ils
arrivent à l'abattoir les veaux a eu
ils sont envoyés à l'âge de trois mois
dans les abattoirs environ pour finir
comme cela alors il ya beaucoup de gens
qui vont me dire moi j'adore les animaux
j'ai du mal à regarder ce genre de
vidéos c'est tout à fait normal c'est ce
qui s'appelle la détresse empathique
en fait lorsque vous et ce genre de 1
d'image ça provoque chez vous de
l'anxiété et vous chercher un
échappatoire physique ou psychologique
pour éviter de penser à cela
moi ce que j'aimerais la prochaine fois
que vous voyez ce genre de vidéos c'est
vous vous mettiez à la place de l'animal
est plutôt que de ressentir la vôtre
votre propre douleur essayé de ressortir
la douleur de l'animal et l'émotion
voilà tourner vers vers l'animal
toujours est il qu'il ya cinq cent mille
vaches au port moutons qui sont abattues
en france chaque jour dans les abattoirs
loin des yeux loin des yeux loin du
coeur alors forcément c'est ces images
elles sont tournées en caméra caché
puisque l'industrie de la viande est là
aucun intérêt à vous montrer ce genre
d'image elle ce qu'elle veut c'est que
vous vous montrez un animal
qui court dans un champ qui rigole avec
ses avec ses copains bien sûr en fait ce
qu'elle cherche
l'industrie de la viande c'est de vous
vendre un produit de consommation
package et comme elle vous vendrait du
papier toilette des vêtements ou autres
produits de consommation
ce qu'elle cherche c'est de dissocier
totalement le le morceau d'anima le
morceau de chair de l'animal à qui il
appartenait et pour cela ils ont inventé
un vocabulaire plus sexy et plus vendeur
et on vous parlait par exemple de de
filet mignon de bavette de tournedos de
bacon
plutôt que de vous dire je vous vends de
la poitrine je vous vends de la chair
des muscles ou des temps dont je vais
parler un petit peu l'élevage intensif
qui représente quand même 85 millions
d'animaux qui vivent actuellement dans
cette dans ces conditions c'est à dire
pas d'accès à l'extérieur pas d'accès à
la lumière du jour dans un environnement
concentrationnaire c'est à dire en
surpopulation sur des cages minuscules
et à nu ou en enfer
les lapins par exemple ils vivent dans
des cages comme vous voyez en haut à
gauche
donc en surpopulation à vingtaine dans
des petites cages de 40 par 90 et ça ça
représente quand même 99 % de tous les
lapins d'élevage en france les canards
et les oies
joyeux noël sont vus dans ces conditions
là et si vous deviez faire l'analogie
avec un humain c'est comme si vous on
vous forcé de manger 7 kg de pâtes deux
fois par jour les ports et les truies
les truies ici elles sont
élevé dans ces conditions là où elle ne
peint des cages où elles ne peuvent même
pas se retourner et où elles peuvent que
très peu avancé
il arrive parfois lorsqu'elle les
allaite leurs petits même qu'elle sait
qu'elle écrase leur leur petit sans
faire attention les ports eux donc les
cochons mâles vivent dans des sur du
béton ils ne peuvent pas exprimer leurs
besoins naturels comme gratter le sol
etc
et il arrive parfois on fait tellement
ils deviennent fous qu'il y à du
cannibalisme en fait entre entre chaque
il arrive à manger voile alors leurs
congénères
ces méthodes d'élevage pour les porcs
ces 95% des ports en france qui sont
élevées de cette manière et enfin les
poules pondeuses
elles sont élevées avec la lutte de la
lumière artificielle pour booster leur
leur production et il arrive parfois
dans le mot qui sont à cent mille ans d
dans des hangars parfois il arrive que
les poulets vivants se promènent au
milieu des cadavres de leurs congénères
je parle un petit peu de la pêche
également enfin d'une date du poisson un
chiffre qui est le camp c'est un kilo de
poing kg de poissons pêchés il ya cinq
kilos de poissons qui ne le sont pas
c'est à dire qu'ils ne sont pas ciblés
pardon ça veut dire que lorsqu'on essaye
de pêcher un kilo de poisson et bas il y
aura cinq kilos de tortues de poissons
aux deux requins de dauphin qui vont
être remontés dans les filets puisqu'on
ne peut pas aller les cibler et du coup
on va leur jeter par dessus bord qui ont
fini au fond des océans
on a inventé un peu le terme pêche
durable pour se donner bonne conscience
et on se donne aussi bonne conscience en
se disant par exemple que la lorsque la
viande est tendre c'est que l'animal n'a
pas souffert on va aussi vous dire que
les animaux
ne souffre pas alors qu'on sait qu'ils
ont les touts les neuro récepteur qui
leur permettre d'éprouver la douleur
sachez par exemple que dans les années
70 on opérait les bébés sans anesthésie
parce qu'on disait qu'il ne souffrait
pas aujourd'hui ça ça nous paraît
inconcevable
on va vous dire que les animaux ne
comprennent pas qu'ils vont à l'abattoir
alors je vous invite à regarder les
vidéos par exemple de l214 sur youtube
vous allez voir que l'animal comprends
très bien là où le destin qui lui est
réservé et il s'est même lorsqu'il est
encore dans le camion
il sait vers quoi il va on va vous dire
également que vous allez manquer de
protéines alors ça aussi c'est un petit
peu un c'est un petit peu comment dire
une ce qu'on se dit depuis depuis très
longtemps
comme vous voyez ici voilà les haricots
ont le même nombre de protéines qu'un
steak mais en plus vous allez avoir des
fibres du fer et du calcium
en plus on va vous dire encore pour se
donner bonne conscience que on va agir
pardon que c'est la sienne alimentaire
excusez moi que le lion lui mange bien
la gazelle oui certes mais le lion est
carnivore
nous on lui il agi par instinct nous on
est omnivore on a le choix de manger de
la viande ou non et surtout on a ce
qu'on appelle la morale ce qui nous
permet de distinguer le bien du mal et
enfin mes arguments préféré pour manger
de la viande c'est on a toujours mangé
de la viande par tradition ça c'est des
images et qui date de 1930 et 1950
c'est ce qu'on appelle à l'époque des os
humains ont capturé des tribus
aborigènes ou africaines et on les
mettait sur la place publique pour que
les gens viennent les admirer
en un demi-siècle 1930 1950 en un demi
siècle environ
on a revu certaines de nos traditions
pour être un peu plus humain alors je
disais les grands perdants c'est d'avoir
les animaux puis ensuite l'environnement
sachez que l'élevage est responsable de
18 % des gaz à effet de serre dans le
monde
c'est plus que le tout le secteur des
transports réunis plus que les voitures
les camions les avions ou les bateaux
c'est principalement dû au fait que
l'élevage dégage du méthane
c'est un gaz qui est vingt fois plus
active comme gaz à effet de serre que le
co2 en termes de consommation d'eau si
c'est catastrophique
l'élevage consomme un tiers de l'eau
douce de la planète
si je prends l'exemple des etats-unis
qui a 5 % de l'eau des états unis qui
est destiné à aux habitations qui est
utilisé par les habitations et 55% de
l'eau qui est utilisé pour les élevages
et oui une vache ça ça boit beaucoup 91%
de la déforestation en amazonie est liée
à l'élevage
en fait on fait pousser on déforeste
dont on enlève des forêts pour faire
pousser des céréales du soja par exemple
qui va d'ailleurs être utilisé pour
nourrir les animaux et en plus qui va
être utilisé pour nourrir nos animaux à
nous en europe par bateau et c'est donc
je vous laisse imaginer le la
catastrophe en terme environnemental un
peu plus proche de chez nous les
élevages bretons si je prends l'exemple
des élevages bretons uniquement il
dégage autant d'excréments que 60
millions d'habitants s'est élevé à ses
excréments vont ensuite polluer les sols
pollués les rivières les nappes
phréatiques et les océans alors vous
allez me dire au lieu de vous préoccuper
des animaux préoccuper au plus tôt des
humains c'est quelque chose que
j'entends souvent en fait c'est les deux
sont liés pour produire 100 g de viande
il faut
100 g de céréales ces 500 grammes de ces
elle pourrait être utilisé ailleurs pour
nourrir par exemple directement les
populations qui en ont besoin
il ya 1 4 milliard de personnes qui
vivent sous le seuil de pauvreté
et elle pourrait être nourri avec les
775 millions de tonnes de grains qu'on
produit annuellement pour les animaux
pour nourrir les animaux
il ya 50% des céréales et des légumes
dans le monde qui sont utilisés pour
nourrir les animaux
par opposition à cela il ya trois
millions d'enfants qui meurent de faim
chaque année c'est à dire un toutes les
11 secondes et enfin 85 % de la
production mondiale de soja est destiné
à l'élevage
le soja c'est une denrée extrêmement
calorique est encore une fois qui
pourraient être utilisés pour nourrir
les les populations qui en ont besoin
directement
alors si vous n'êtes ni intéressé par le
sort des animaux ni par celui de
l'environnement
peut-être êtes-vous intéressé par votre
santé sachez que le cholestérol vient
que de quatre aliments qui sont le lait
le fromage les oeufs et la viande
d'ailleurs il y en a pas la viande
industrielle a été classée par
l'organisation mondiale de la santé
comme cancérigène deux groupes un dont
je parle de la viande industrielle le
groupe un des aliments cancérigènes
c'est le tabac l'alcool et les drogues
la viande rouge non industriel et dans
le groupe 2 il ya beaucoup
étude qui montre le lien entre la
consommation de viande et des cancers
comme le cancer du côlon les maladies
cardiovasculaires ou le diabète
ça c'est par exemple que lorsque vous
mangez 50 grammes de viande rouge par un
jour vous augmentez vos chances d'avoir
enfin pour risque d'avoir un diabète de
51% alors vous allez me dire je vais
manger plutôt du poulet en fait le
poulet niveau cholestérol c'est à peu
près pareil sauf que en raison de ces
conditions d'élevage le pou les poulets
sont gavés d'antibiotiques et ces
antibiotiques vous allez les ingurgiter
dans l'autre ils vont se retrouver en
fait dans votre assiette
et du coup vous allez développer ce
qu'on appelle l'antibiorésistance c'est
à dire la capacité de vos de vous de vos
bacs tiré à muter et à devenir
résistantes contre les antibiotiques et
l'om est ce encore une fois dit que en
2005 en tuera plus de morts liées à
l'antibiorésistance que au cancer alors
forcément ce que je viens de vous dire
aujourd'hui c'est pas forcément très
réjouissant mais heureusement il y a des
motifs d'espoir comme par exemple le
fait que c'est un sujet d'actualité
qu'on en parle et que je pense qu'il ya
derrière cela une prise de conscience
qu'il ya de plus en plus d'alternatives
végétale à la viande dans les magasins
ou aux restaurants par exemple qu'à une
loi aussi qui dit qu' à partir de 2020
je crois dans tous les universités il y
aura un menu végétarien par semaine donc
tout ça ça me donne un peu des motifs
d'espoir
ce que j'aimerais aujourd'hui c'est vous
redonner un peu l'innocence et la
bienveillance que vous aillez que vous
aviez lorsque vous étiez petit à l'égard
des animaux et je trouve que le système
vous à vous enlevez vous comme à moi
et du coup je vous je vous invite à
faire vos choix est à faire vos propres
recherches maintenant mais n'oubliez pas
lorsque vous allez faire vos recherches
n'oubliez pas que 90% de la presse
française est détenue par seulement 11
milliardaire ces onze milliardaires ils
ont forcément un intérêt à vous faire
passer une information plutôt qu'une
autre
lorsque vous allez vous vous intéressez
à ce sujet je l'espère vérifier
plusieurs fois vos sources
est ce que j'aimerais vous dire
aujourd'hui c'est dans votre manière de
vous alimentez comme dans votre manière
de consommer l'information arrêté
d'avaler n'importe quoi merci
[Applaudissements]